As we all know,
Jung Draw Gaming released his highly
anticipated Nicholas Dioro video. Highly
rushed Nicholas review. Thank you,
Caesar, for the 1999. Huge appreciated
with the lemon character super sticker
bowing in front of a rose bush burst
into bloom as he does so. Thank you.
Much anticipated Junk Draw Gaming video
just came out about Nick Dioro.
Great video. Great video. some flaws,
but you know, broad broadly good.
Broadly good.
And Nick Doro responded to it. We didn't
go over his response the other day, but
he did respond to it in his Discord.
Obviously, that's where he speaks about
videos that he's less confident uh
framing to his audience and where he
doesn't want the criticism seen by his
audience. The Alex Neville video he'll
respond to on stream because Alex
Neville is a Hassan Orbiter and Nick can
very easily frame it alongside with the
fuckups about the revenue that Alex had.
uh he can much easier frame it as um
less critical of him, less uh impactful
and just just deal with sweeping for
Ethan. Meanwhile, this is a much closer
indictment on Nick that you might have
to actually struggle through a little
bit and try to explain himself on. So,
he will not respond to that on stream.
He'll just cry about in his Discord.
Thank you for the $10, Commodore Trump.
Huge appreciate with the super sticker,
the pair character flying through like
Superman. Thank you. Huge appreciate.
Thanks so much. I didn't hate the Junk
Draw gaming video. I was just annoyed
with it. I'm just annoyed with him. I'm
just annoyed with Junk Draw.
I'm annoyed with video essaists. I hate
the way that they spend ages
like doing [__] nothing and then
they're like, "Okay, so you I think I
said this. This how Junk Draw made this
video. He was he was going to make it he
was going to make it for ages and he
makes a bet about Aiden's Discord and
getting banned if he doesn't do it by
New Year's." So he rushes it out in like
on like New Year's Eve and the day
before or some [__] and has to like
constantly use loopholes saying, "Oh,
I'm in American Samoa. It's not New
Year's yet. I'm on Baker Island. It's
not New Year's yet."
And he he like makes these excuses like
so so he finally does it around then and
then he's making excuses like, "Oh, I
have a job. I can't just work on
videos." Bro, check Discord. I see him
in VCs like every night.
spend some of the time that you would
spend playing [__] Minecraft with
AIDS gangers, making your [__] video.
I beg.
And then you get [__] Nandros
spending like, you know, a full year on
his
fully animated Magnum Opus, you know?
So, you really don't you really don't
need that. You really don't need that.
Make make like three videos if you
really need to if you really need to
spend that much time on it. Kilo is a
whole different issue. Kilo is just like
a whole different issue. Kilo's
nightmarish, too. But I've I've at least
got confidence that Kilo is going to
release a quality product
at some point. Okay? I don't have a lot
of faith in Teen Tony. I'm going to be
real. Okay? And he's unproven. He's
untested.
Well, I I wait to be blown away. I wait
to I await being blown away, but I don't
hold my breath. I'm just being honest.
Okay. Liquid Sonic though. Liquid Sonic
just puts [__] out. You know what I
mean? This guy is just just works.
>> I'm behind on the stream. Was there more
to the Venezuela story than Crazy
America did that?
>> No, I haven't done a full proper
coverage of the Venezuela thing. That
was kind of like um
it was kind of halfhearted. Thank you
for the $5. We're just getting into the
stream. So yeah, Liquid Sonic
puts puts in work. We we love Liquid
Sonic. My trailer is gas. Oh, wait. Can
we show the trailer? Can we show the
Kilo trailer, guys? Exclusive here.
Exclusive airing of the Kilo trailer in
this Nick Dorio segment. You look around
the scene, right, and you see people
like Hassan [__] with his crocodile
tears. This was his reaction to the
shooting. I cannot believe this
hypocrite who's been advocating for
political violence for years now
pretending like he's shocked something
like this would happen. No, dude. Not
you. You are disgusting. I am so tired
of this man and his violent rhetoric
crying on stream. No, no, no, no. Not
you, man. Not you. It's so obviously
[music] a call to violence. You're
obviously wrong for saying it. There's
no justification at all to say something
like that.
>> I feel like I've seen a few different
clips of Hassan saying like, "Well, we
don't really know for sure if if Kamla
would have been different."
>> And once again, we have Hassan engaging
in activities which may very well
violate California law.
>> Sam, another one I'm ready to burn cuz
he also like protects [music] Hassan at
all cost.
>> God, I [__] hate Hassan so much.
Hassan is a [__] stupid tanky
jihadist apologizing piece of [__] [__]
Hassan. What a [__] [__] Because
Hassan is the most unlikable human being
on earth unless you want to have sex
with him.
>> Like when when when we go to his
channel, I got to stop talking about
Hassan so much to be honest with you.
[music]
>> It just bothers me that like um
>> Okay, so you think that Hassan is not
fun to talk to about anime?
>> I I I think normalizing Hassan is
dangerous.
>> One of your biggest stars, Hassan, is
one of the most genuinely evil,
disgusting, disreputable people on the
planet. I genuinely do believe that
Hassan is one of the worst people on the
internet.
>> Hassan [__] is the most dangerous
person that if you're over the age of
about 35, you've probably never heard
of. So Hassan is one of the most
terrible human beings on earth.
>> At least your villain Ethan Klein showed
real emotion. And when he discovered the
news on his podcast, he was sobbing. And
I believe his tears. I don't believe
Hassan Piker's crocodile tears. The
people that simp for Hassan who are like
he's hot whatever. It's so pathetic.
Even if you think it's hot, just it's so
embarrassing. It's so cringe. Guys,
please. I'm going to [__] die.
>> I haven't seen you in pretty much never.
>> Yeah.
>> You want to be in my vlog?
>> Sure.
>> Starting it up.
>> Oh, hell yeah. I just started I just
started vlogging.
>> Recently as well.
>> I feel you. It's hard. It's awkward. I
actually I came here to say thank you.
>> Wait, why? No, thank you
>> for supporting Teddy Fry so much.
>> Thank you for the the big baggy pants. I
love them so much. Oh my god.
>> Well, have a good show.
>> Thank you. Bye everybody.
[laughter]
>> Dude, you can't use that. That's
anti-Semitic to use this angle of
healer. To use this angle of angle of
healer. This is anti-semitic.
You you're not allowed to use this angle
of healer because it's anti-Semitic to
show healer from that angle.
>> Well, have a good show.
>> Thank you. Bye everybody.
>> Dude,
she's doing a lar chill. [music]
Oh,
wow. What a what a trailer, guys. Wow.
What a what a trailer.
Make sure you sub to Kilo, guys. Make
sure I'll link the Kilo's channel. Okay,
so getting into these Dorio Discord
leaks.
I briefly mentioned the death. So, okay.
Yeah. So, he's responding to a Junk Draw
Gaming video here. Obviously, one of the
first points in the Junk Draw Gaming
video
was um
Oh, wait. Actually, should we go back
further? No, he's going further. Let's
see his full Discord reaction to it.
Just got recommended. This feels like I
watched a video from Cruel World Happy
Mind. Dude, you can't you cannot wake it
up. They are beyond parody. Dude, this
is like this is like a tipster video.
This is like one of the recent Ethan
Klein enemies. If you haven't followed
every step of the EHD stuff, you won't
know. Cruel Happy Mind. Okay. Something
that I didn't even cover properly cuz it
was just it's just Ethan beating on
another like
bad optics woman. You know, there's
there's like a crazy looking kind of
crazy woman. Ethan beats on her for
talking about him and everyone everyone
walks away going, "Oh, Ethan's so
awesome." She's another one of those as
always.
>> [clears throat]
>> Damn, is that bad, L?
Disgusting comment. And so you guys may
see the comment here, but I'll read it
to you. MPS and skulls. Nick is whoever
his current daddy is. He did Metacica,
Keemstar, Destiny, and now Ethan.
Um, heat facts. Straight straight facts.
Heat patriot. W Ashley W. Ashley. I
mean, yeah, nothing even objectionable
about that comment.
Disgusting comment. What a loser of a
channel. I didn't even dig deep and it's
[laughter] like they really don't like
this tweet. They really don't like this
salvo tweet.
Willy Max very Zionist 2025.
Marries an Israeli Jew. Ethan Klein pays
for Willy's wedding. Starts making
propaganda for the clients. Goes to
Israel for honeymoon during the war. now
calling out Candace Owens with very
generic pro-Israel talking points.
Let's uh see the rest of this tweet.
Sorry, I feel like maybe there's some I
wouldn't want to take Salvo's words out
of context here. So, I need to make sure
we get the full tweet here. We can't we
can't be taking Salvo's words out of
context. That's the sort of thing thing
uh Nikki D would do. He's unfairly
maligned Salvo.
Who is his wife? Who are Australia's
Israeli in-laws? Is he accepting money
from clients and pros radio orgs? All
will be disclosed.
Oh, sorry. Wait, there was Sorry, that
wasn't vindicating contact. Sorry, guys.
I must have Sorry. No, he [laughter]
10 years. Bad luck.
Okay, so I had this
I I guess Wait, maybe I talk about this.
I had this brief disagreement with um
recurring character
Griley.
Recurring Nicholas Dioro Discord
character, Griley.
It's Griley. This is a woman. This is a
um I believe
I I'm stabbing in the dark a little bit
here. I think a dransitioned FTM
middle-aged woman
who Wait, no, they weren't dransitioned.
They just said like
they felt like a guy some days but then
got over it or some [__] when they were
talking about Bo Bob Bolex, I think. Um,
but yeah, this I I like this character.
I do like this character because
you guys will remember if you're oldhead
Nicholas Dioro fans. And by oldhead, I
mean literally like a year ago,
two years ago maybe. So, not even old
head, just like when I was hanging
around him. You guys may remember this
Nicholas Diora guy going ballistic
going on a
total [__] war path against um what's
her name Brainy Biscuit
the YouTube drama moderator and they
were posting like when they post like
suicide notes and he was going like
crazy at them and [__] So, it's just
amusing to me that now he's got his own
like super mentally ill
[__] Discord channel
that like loss out and gets into these
[__] public fights.
So, let's just pull up this tweet that's
in this uh in this image. So, okay, I'll
just show the context here as well
actually. So, Guam, we know Guam. Do we
know Guam? Girl with a microphone.
Nicole Dioro. Yeah, Nicole Dioro.
So, there's this tweet by Hassan.
I've spent the last decade talking about
the separation of Zionism and Judaism.
And while conceptually is true, these
sorts of images make a much stronger
argument against said separation, then
people wonder why anti-semitism grows.
This is a big part of the reason why.
So, it's Netanyahu getting a hero's
welcome in a Miami synagogue. Obviously,
the point here being
if you don't want Jews to be associated
with the crimes of Israel,
these are terrible things to do.
Much like you might say, if you don't
want Muslims to be associated with the
crimes of
Hamas,
maybe cheering them on isn't a smart
thing to do.
There there are many comments you can
make like this when people are doing
terrible, insane, bad optics things that
are totally reasonable to make
and don't necessarily mean that you
think there is a inherent problem with
that group or whatever, right? And Guam
here is saying, "So now Hassan is
literally saying there's no separation
between Jews and Zionists and blaming
anti-semitism on Jews. [__] this guy for
real.
No, he's I've spent the last decade
talking about the separation of Zionism
and Judaism and what conceptually it is
true. These sorts of images make it look
different. She made a whole video on
this. Maybe we'll take a look at it
later. So yeah, and I reply basically
calling a stupid [__] That's not that
important. Also, what we're really here
for is this Grizzly tweet. So yeah,
Grizzly replies to my reply to Guam
saying, "Baha, you're so pathetic,
Queen. I hope 2026 is equal to the rest
of your life. Peace and love. Now, my
2025 was pretty pretty good and 2026 is
starting well. However, this person
appears to be in Discord
in the Nicholas Dioro Discord saying,
"I have skits. I have ADHD. I'm
autistic. Undiagnosed bipolar or
borderline. Who knows? I'm probably
narcissistic as [__] and have major
anxiety and depression. Insert here a
list of things wrong with me. Don't make
fun of me. It's a wild list mix of
things. Makes me very unstable and
untrustworthy person when it was all
happening. Mental illness hit later.
Retalation was from birth. I see a lot
of my early self and current Bob except
not everything.
[clears throat]
So I I saw his post said, "Happy New
Year to H3 Dioro janitorial team." And
they spent like the next six hours
talking about in Discord. Soar
apparently this is
me being raped.
I mean IDF Smiley here says, "Honestly,
I would have just ignored him. He's
pathetic and a loser who's falling off
and looking for any way to get
relevance. If you ignore him, he might
get down to 50 viewers quicker and he'll
quit, god willing. Not happening." Now I
love proddding at Quiqu.
She's interesting. One of the few things
I engage with on Twitter cuz always
recognizes me and responds. Quefman and
Laura Luma. Only two kns I post. Well,
Quei Queen. Did you call Just call him
Quiqueen? And she I had no idea Queefman
was trans. Congratulations to him. I
mean, it was pretty obvious that he
Sorry, she was a woman the way he she
cries and so at everything. Okay, I'm
being targeted. I think
that private big picture does not bode
well.
So, let me see here.
I mean, you did get clapped kind of.
You're super ashamed of yourself, aren't
you? I ain't got that problem. Don't
worry.
What?
Where did that come from? Seems like
protection. I ain't bothered by my own
words. Projection. FML. Close enough.
Haha. How you got raped in the
marketplace of ideas and posted to
Discord as if it was a win. Gristly, I
don't dislike you, but that post you
made was cringe.
I I love this chatter. Julia Collins
777. Stylo, do not time out that
chatter. Stylo, do not moderate that
chatter.
Tick. Jixer updates. Emily Hernandez, 10
years prison, lethal DUI. Andrew Johnson
charged with sexual abuse of an
11-year-old.
Uh John Benuelos kidnapping sexual
assault. Andrew Teague, guilty of
celesting a 15year-old. H
No, they don't. They're not a dog, sir.
They're not a dog, sir. They're not a
dog, sir.
I don't know how long you did the time
out. Whatever for just under it wasn't
It's not a dog. They're just giving um
They just come in and do lip slop
talking points.
with emojis. With emojis. So, they're
just listing out January 6es and uh
saying what else I've been arrested for.
Okay. [laughter]
Me talking about myself isn't a win. It
wasn't anything. L.
And you got clapped by Queen. But keep
thinking about it. I'm a sad lonely
faile. It's some embarrassing
information. I enjoy coping. I'm going
to go watch some movies. How did he
cope? Any disturbance to the Hugbox is
coping? What Hugbox? Do you guys know
where you are? Lol. Oh, you you on the
mean streets of the Nicholas Dioro
Patreon Discord.
You you you don't even know what it's
like out here in the Nicholas Dioro
Patreon Discord. Do you not know where
you are?
Oh, I feel so hugged right now. You
really haven't noticed a shift over the
year where every opinion has merged into
one. You ever noticed an uptick of NPC
H3 wine moms?
Uhoh.
Discontent.
You wish you were hugged right now. I
bet. But you won't get that from real
inserts like me and car. Okay.
Man, you guys put way too much stock in
online words. Lol.
You can just say, [laughter] "Okay."
Yeah, they usually have their face as a
PFP and look like Lindsay Ellis.
You put too much offline words online.
Yeah, right. Pop off girl. You like the
Stranger Things finale where he defeats
someone by coming out of the closet.
It's a circified Nick. I haven't watched
it season 2, but I'm glad you have gay
representation now. Wow.
Okay. So then Nick shows up. I watched
the first four minutes of that video.
His first argument was how I never
condemned Ethan for making the snarred
his death about himself. So let's check.
Let's have a look. Did Junk Draw say
Nick has never spoken about this
or did he say he didn't cover it?
Because he didn't do actual coverage of
it, did he? [music]
>> Sexual assault. Come on.
So that's not the first argument anyway.
>> All I did was tweet out like support for
>> it's far from the first argument
actually
>> terrorist. It's just like
>> changed in some tremendous way. Death is
a way
>> 20 Ethan. Let's look at some of the main
criticisms that Nick used against Ethan
in his 2020 video series. Nick
>> to this expination
of mental health issues and criticism
that she received both online and in
real life regarding the way she ran her
animal sanctuary. Most of the online
harassment she received was from Kiwi
Farms, Tumblr, and a very inactive Snark
subreddit, which only had 19 posts in
total at the time of her death. Ethan
Klein very quickly decided to make this
woman suicide about himself, claiming
that her snark subreddit was the
deciding factor in her death and
comparing it to his own snark subreddit,
claiming that their end goal is to get
him to kill himself. In reality,
Michaela's death had very little, if
anything, to do with her tiny snark
subreddit and likely had much more to do
with the harassment and criticism that
she received from other sanctuaries in
real life in combination with her mental
health struggles. This didn't stop Ethan
from turning the spotlight on himself in
an effort to remove criticism of himself
from the internet. It would seem like
Dioro doesn't personally agree with the
assessment that Michaela Snark subreddit
was the reason she killed herself.
>> So yeah. Yeah. A girl save a fox killed
herself from
>> So okay. So it seems like Nick doesn't
agree
>> on a snark [music] sub. It is crazy. And
yet I just I completely disagree with
this.
>> Reddit does nothing and there is no
account. But despite boldly disagreeing
with Ethan on this over six months
later, Nick still has never addressed
Ethan weaponizing this woman's death to
bolster his campaign to remove his
detractor base from the internet. Ethan
Klein even made Charlie Kirk's death
about himself within hours of
>> So he never addressed the fact that
Ethan made it about himself.
So has Nick ever addressed that? Let's
see.
Let's see. I think Nick tried to present
a clip.
Let's see. Look, I'm not going to say
that Ethan hasn't done stuff like this.
Ethan absolutely has like jumped in and
and and kind of um I guess I guess like
interjected his own situation into like
clips that pop up. I just find this so
[__] shameless. The DHS security shot
her puppy,
>> dude. He said Ethan has kind of
interjected his story into clips that
pop up. Okay. But then says this is so
Sheamus. So what is H Assan saying?
Hassan is saying the virtue signaling
and bear in mind this is literally like
eight months after this story happened.
By the way, this is eight months after
the save [__] [__] happened. Nick didn't
address it at the time. This is just
like the other [__] literally the
other week. It's literally the other
week Nick said this. Okay, he didn't
address it at the time. He it was
notable that he didn't address it
because Alex Gekko made a whole big
thing about it about how Nick needs to
address it because it's the most obvious
thing that would be top news story for
Hassan if Hassan had done it. Anyone
have done it be top news story and if
Nick doesn't cover this properly it's
obvious he's compromised and lo and
behold you didn't cover it. So this is
eight months after when it's all passed
when Ethan stopped talking about it.
Nick finds the balls to finally say
Ethan has kind of interjected his story
into like clips that show up sometimes
and then is downplaying it by saying
that Hassan saying that people are
virtue signaling about his dog because
they don't care about [__] Chrissy
Gnome shooting her dog and this [__]
Hassan saying that is worse apparently
than Ethan using a still warm body to
try and silence criticism about himself.
something that Nick, as Junk draw
pointed out in that video of the Etica
stuff, has taken a massive stand on
before
when these these two are the severity
here is the difference is insane, right?
Her son shocks his dog and says, "Well,
you really care about this when Christy
Gnome shot hers
versus Ethan saying, "You you guys
talking bad about me on the internet? I
end up killing myself like this like
this insane woman that just killed
herself. This woman just killed herself
cuz you guys were forcing her to do it.
Yeah, sure. One of cuz someone's so much
worse, isn't he? Nice one, fatty. Nice
one, you [__] idiot. Let's keep
watching the clip.
>> Ian wrote about in a book, cops kill
10,000 dogs a year. A decent number of
people who support all this think I
abuse my dog cuz she sometimes sleeps
behind me. I think the one that like if
we're going to make a critique towards
Ethan, the one that sticks in the back
of my mind, I think we covered it
briefly was there was a clip that came
out. What was it? Someone killed
themselves on on Reddit or something. Uh
like a Redditor killed themselves
>> and they were blaming like a snark
subreddit that did it. But then
>> nope.
>> And a couple hours later once people did
research.
>> So Nick has even lied about the story
here. Nick has lied about the story.
They didn't claim it was the Snark
credit. They were not blaming the
[__] Snark credit.
They said there was some online
harassment. They were non-specific, but
mainly in real life. It was mainly
issues with people in real life.
Thank you for the membership donator.
Thank you. There were like hardly any
posts in this subreddit. All the posts
were like low up votes or whatever. Like
nobody actually like interacted with the
Snark community. And it realistically
didn't have anything to do with or it
didn't play a large role in what
happened to that person. Like the snark
community was extremely small. Um and
then it kind of got pushed into like
this is the danger of snark communities
or whatever. It got like it got pushed
into you see hear how detached it is. It
just got pushed that way. Thank you
Critical Shogun for the membership.
Thank you. What you mean to say, Nick,
is Ethan Klein weaponized it? He
weaponized a woman's suicide like the
day it happened to try to silence
criticism. That's what you mean, Nick.
That's what you mean to say. It's so
pathetic. It's so [__] pathetic.
>> Maybe waiting.
>> Yeah. just the disembodied force that
weaponized this
>> to kind of see how things turn out
before jumping on that would benefit
everybody. I think I disagreed with Dan
on that, right? Dan Salman posted it as
well and I think Ethan posted it to his
story. It was a lady from Sabah Fox.
What else do we got here? [laughter]
>> Pathetic. Yeah, this is the same passive
language Destiny used when recounting
his divorce, dude.
No, he was very active though. He was
dodging his ex-wife ex-wife's lies like
Neo from the Matrix.
Okay.
[clears throat]
So, the next disco message, let's see
this.
I briefly mentioned the death on the
first day. I don't believe he did. Said
to Dan Saltman that Ethan misreported it
as well as the following stream. I'm
pretty sure I mentioned it as an example
when I of when I disagreed with Ethan.
So, I I do not remember reporting on
this at all. Don't remember reporting
this at all. And it's just it's insane
to suggest that you're going, "Oh, yeah.
I disagree." Like that's substant that
is substantive criticism,
bro. Everybody knows. Everybody with
their [__] head intact knows this
would be headliner about anyone else if
they were pulling this [__] Any other
subject of a Nick Duro stream, this
would be headliner topic. this psychotic
[__] loser is weaponizing the still
warm corpse of some YouTuber, some kind
of retired YouTuber I think at that
point. Um to to
silence criticism about themselves. That
would be literally top [__] story.
Like this clip is literally me
condemning a Hassan action and using
Ethan as an example of a time where he
did the same. No, you implied that
Ethan's wasn't as bad even though it's
like obviously way worse. Dude, it's
like crazy.
You used the son's action to downplay
Ethan's if anything. So then guys, we
get something great here. We get once
again
Nicholas Dioro's petulent [__] ass
[__]
narcissistic ass wounded ego ass [__]
[__] estrogenic side come out in some
of these messages, guys. Some of these
messages. some real bitterness, some
real resentment coming out of this
[__] tits ah [__] loser. So, let's
take a look at some of this.
I will say you're never beating the H
post H3 show allegations l but I feel a
lot that they levy against you think but
I feel a lot that levy that against you
think it's because you don't want to
stomp on their stream
when in reality because oft they're done
so you can catch stuff.
I mean if I quit my job and start
streaming directly over them I will l
I'm selfish. I only want you to start
soon so I can watch live. If the
criticism is the topics then sure but
it's a stream time thing. Google 8 hour
work days l so I don't know who is
criticizing him over stream topics or
start time or what this person is like
making up this criticism. It's like a
something no one has ever said.
As far as I understand Nick has always
started at the same time. I think anyone
says otherwise.
This is just like so [__]
But obviously this is the only criticism
Nick thinks is happening or well claims
he thinks is happening. He thinks all
anyone is saying is I don't like the
topics you cover.
It's just so [__] [__] I I just
can't take it.
The the feigned,
you know, like retellation is is just
obs.
I would love to start my streams at 4:00
or sooner every day and actually get
sleep at night time. If I were to leech
hard off Ethan's audience, I could be I
would be a morning stream and farm money
before they spend it all on Ethan. I'd
probably do better in that time slot
running against Chud. So, here we go.
And I could kill Chud if I wanted to.
I'd kill Ch. So, it keeps going, guys.
It keeps going. So, I think that's
basically all the Dior messages about
the junk draw video.
So, I know guys, if you're expecting a
meltdown, I I over I overpromised,
but hopefully that was funny for you
anyway. Hope that was funny for you.
Anyway, but we have got a little bit
more here. Yeah, solid bit of DRA snark.
So, what we got here?
This is a Dicker's video it seems.
They're saying, "Yeah, I saw that
earlier. Dickers reacting to that other
video. I'm watching it now. This is
pretty gay." Yep. Lau almost I think we
show this almost cru level of research.
It's worse. I think I was like all the
bad faith [__] Wait, no. They're just
saying this again. They're just saying
the same [__] again. This is a different
screenshot. They're just saying [__]
the same comparison again, dude.
I hate people like this so much.
If a dicker's video gets you riled up,
you lost. Anytime you you click on a
dicker's video and watch for more than
10 seconds, anytime you click on a
dicker's video, you lost. But if you
watch more than 10 seconds, you have
lost by default. It's like all the bad
faith [__] As soon as I saw them adopt
like you know these people are [__]
when all they can do is go you're bad
faith you're bad faith you're bad faith
a pedophile dog whistle by the way on on
par with the little swirly thing that
Liam Donovan likes to wear on par with
that to be honest saying bad faith like
this as soon as I saw them adopt Denim's
arguments and to back her up I knew it
being a wild ride so Denim's argument is
just correct
denim's argument about her chat is just
correct.
Sorry. Darm or mean people can be right
sometimes. She she is just correct about
the way Ethan lied about it and the way
Nick lied about it. Him saying that Nick
and Ethan support Dan's doxing and Nick
supported the fox go suicide [__] I
knew it was a ride.
I don't think it said that he supported
the fox girl suicide [__] I'm not
surprised. He is Isn't he a queen and
nut hanger?
Apparently everyone is. Apparently,
everyone is. Oh [__] I forgot about
that. Yeah. Does he defend the CPS call?
Who does? Dick is in the videos watching
cuz he defends why Trisha's snark was
taken down because they involved her
kids. I know the queen and says it's
just Ethan self victimizing which is
[__] crazy.
So I say what is self victimizing? I say
I say that he self victim. He does self
victimize over Yeah, he does victimize
stuff over the CPS [__] and weaponize
it. Yes. Yes. Yes. Yes. Yes. Makes makes
sense. Queen got raped because of the
Destiny drama. Huh.
Huh. I mean, Huh. I mean, it certainly
guys, I'm sorry. All I can think about
is my tax bill right now. All I'm
thinking about is my tax bill.
In a way. In a way, I did cuz, you know,
I'm having to pay out the ass now. You
know, in a way, when you think about it.
Okay, found it. He is defending CPS it
seems who's defending CPS. You were the
only person who wasn't raped on that
situation.
Makes it Queen Rig. He did. I thought he
did a pretty good job with some of the
destiny coverage. What did he do? The
overextending at Smackdown. He just
pivoted to a Hassan defender like Jook
did from my understanding. Quan to be
clear.
Yeah. If you if you if you have like the
most one-dimensional view of everything
ever, then yeah, I'm I just pivot as
being a sound defender. Sure. Sure, man.
I text him, too. We text every night. He
tells me what to say on stream.
That's so aids. I don't understand how a
drama stream becomes sidescing
money. What? What do you
You watch Nicholas Dioro. You watch
Nicholas Dioro. He does not sit on the
sidelines point and laugh and raking
money.
He is on Ethan's side explicitly.
Yeah, this person has to be a troll,
right? Like surely [laughter] this a
troll. Surely this is like Kathy or
something.
The the transisraeli flag with IDF
Smiley.
This is Kathy. Surely. Well, the thing
is I could see sort of like a drama.
I could totally see this being
Well, the thing is that
I would I could see it being a
transisraeli or a trans Jew
that's like a
liberal Zionist type that watches H3 and
Dioro, but that sort of person would
defend destiny. Surely
all the all the trans Zionist people
defend destiny because they don't care
if women get raped because you know
not risk.
That's my sense anyway from Twitter. I
mean we're really shocked a guy that
uses that name Kino Casino made for Vue
USA as a way to make fun of him as a
psycho. Maybe he steals his sister's
eyes. I don't know. See this is so
authentic. This is so authentic being
like a local consumer like this. Dickers
is the name that they call review tech
USA.
Uh I don't know what this other part is
about. Stealing sister's eyes. I don't
know what that's about. XD,
my hope for common sense seem to be only
alive here, right?
Shows them up his ass and uses them as
anal beads. See, this person is too
vulgar and and [__]
H I need more uh I need more Doro snark
to fill that out a segment. Guys, we've
got this.
>> Life things. You need to go to therapy.
>> Nick, I'm about to permanently move to
Israel and this might be my last stream
for a while. You better make it a good
one. Shout out all my Habad Chassidam in
chat.
>> Thank you very much. Good luck with
that. [laughter] Um, so Stoic Chronicles
has posted a lot here.
Okay. Okay. So this is like so months
after the
Saber Fox thing happens. So he doesn't
talk about at the time, but he does
bring it up to Dan when they have their
debate.
I knew that the whole like the the Fox
person uh that that whole suicide
situation. I was like, I don't think
this is a snark issue. I thought it
right away before anyone said it. And I
saw a lot of people on Twitter.
>> So you weren't in on that? I saw a lot
of people who just immediately assume I
think even even Ethan to an extent kind
of assumed
>> no you know what I you know what I did I
instantly went and I looked at uh the
subreddit and how many posts were there
and they were all from like one person
and it was like 10 and I was like okay
whatever. So, dude, wait. Didn't Nick
just say that he this he fought with Dan
over this? Dan
is [__] saying here he didn't believe
it. Dan said to Nick, "I don't believe
this."
Nick didn't bring it up and go to Dan.
Dan's here saying, "I didn't believe
this."
>> A lot of people on Twitter.
>> Oh, so you weren't in on that? I saw a
lot of people.
>> Okay, Dan wins again. That's what we
love. Ethan to an extent kind of.
>> No, you know what I You know what I did?
I instantly went and I
>> Yeah. Even Ethan to an extent. Ethan was
the one pushing it. It only got picked
up as a snark issue because Ethan was
going around saying it, pushing it.
That's the He was the one doing it and
you were like, "Oh, I don't want to say
anything about that." Dude, it's so
transparent. He's such a pathetic
rodent.
Nick is such a [__]
low life, dude.
Bro, it's l you can just watch clips of
this guy. There are endless clips of
this guy just being the most disgusting
[__] low life.
Every time he says something this why he
doesn't take positions or defend himself
against stuff like the junk draw video
cuz every time he tries there's always
he's always lying. He's always lying
because he is just like fat person
mindset, disgusting,
low IQ, loweffort approach to
everything. Jesus man. Jesus.